a lot of people exercise because they
believe it will help them to lose fat
one of the biggest debates on the planet
what advice have you got for me so this
is not a well-known fact but Daniel
Lieberman he studies and teaches humans
are supposed to live author and
professor at Harvard University exercise
disease sleep nutrition he has the
answers and all of those things that
most of us care about we evolve to be
very Physically Active working in the
fields hunting Gathering but now we live
in a world where only 50 of Americans
ever exercise and the rest of the world
is headed our way cancers depression
anxiety can attribute that to less
physical activity in fact women who get
150 minutes of physical activity a week
have a 30 to 50 percent lower breast
cancer risks and it's crazy right the
problem is that we spend three percent
of our medical Budget on prevention and
yet 75 of the time the disease is a
preventable disease it's a completely
backward stupid system when you started
writing this book about exercise was
there any instant changes that you
implemented into your own life strength
training the more I study the importance
of doing weights especially as you age
the more I started kicking myself for
being lazy about that when people retire
they're become less active they tend to
lose muscle and then that starts off a
vicious cycle so would you say we
shouldn't retire it's a very modern
Western concept and yes we do pay a
price for it so how does one go from
having a negative opinion towards
exercise to becoming an exerciser as an
evolutionary biologist there are
multiple ways of doing that so Daniel
what are some of the biggest myths
within exercise gosh there are so many
one of the most common of course is
Daniel Lieberman he's been to every
corner of the world visiting native
tribes to understand how humans are
supposed to live and now he has the
answers and all of those things that
most of us care about on sleep nutrition
exercise disease you know on disease he
says that 74 of them can be prevented
and he knows how to prevent them aging
running are we born to run he tells me
the story of a CEO that forces his
employees to exercise and the impact
that that's had on that company and he
talks about how as humans we've evolved
to either use it or lose it
so maybe maybe retirement is a really
bad idea for many of us one of the most
thought-provoking pivotal conversations
I've had on the show you're really going
to take a lot from this one and I
suspect after listening you'll probably
start running too
for exercise or from some of the
decisions you've spent your life making
[Music]
your work is so so incredibly impressive
reaches such an incredible depth
Charter's new territory and it's been
an unbelievable
clearly very passion driven career you
had so my first question for you is why
are you doing this
um
it's a good question
um I um you know I started off being
obsessed by a human evolution ever since
I was a kid I was really interested in
human evolution and I spent much of my
early career working on skulls and heads
and why they are the way they are and
then I kind of got involved in public
health and issues of health and disease
kind of through the back door I sort of
slowly shifted my research trajectory
towards studying the evolution of
running and then the evolution of
physical activity and its relationship
to health and disease and and I've
become part of a movement that's often
known as evolutionary medicine which is
how to apply evolutionary theory and
data to issues of health and disease
evolutionary medicine I've never heard
that term before but I love it
where has your work on evolutionary
medicine let's call it where has that
taken you where where has it taken you
to learn to research to study
you know so much of what we think about
in terms of health and disease comes
from a tiny fragment of the world's
population almost entirely like 90 of
all the medical information comes from
people from the United States Canada
Europe and Australia so in order to
study how bodies really work and how our
bodies evolve to be you have to leave
places like Boston where I live and go
to places like Africa or Mexico or
wherever to look at at other populations
and look at how those populations are
transitioning to to Lifestyles like mine
and so we've been working in Kenya for
the last 15 years or so and I've
traveled some other parts of the world
as well India you know to kind of
collect some data but uh but mostly in
mostly in Africa after doing all of this
work and after taking in all of this
information how has it shifted your
perspective on
running exercise more broadly what have
there been any sort of significant
cognitive perception changes you know
yeah
um I actually had a I mean it doesn't
happen very often but I had kind of an
epiphany moment um when I was working in
Mexico we were collecting data on the
tarahumaro very also famous for their
long distance running and there was this
elderly guy he's about 70 something
years old and he's famous for his
distance running and I was asking him
how he trained and I had asked this
question of a whole bunch of other
people and the translator I was working
with was always struggling to ask that
question because it turns out there's no
word for training in in that language
the concept of training doesn't exist so
so she was trying to explain to this guy
what my question was
um and I could even a translator I could
figure out just from his tone of voice
he was like why would anybody run if you
didn't have to
and I suddenly realized yeah of course
exercise
is a very weird thing right well if
you're if you're a farmer and you're
working super hard every day in the
field without machines and whatever or
if you're a hunter-gatherer and you're
walking you know you know five to ten
miles a day and digging and throwing you
know doing all kinds of hard work and
you're barely getting enough enough food
why on Earth would you go for a needless
five mile run in the morning I mean it's
crazy right
the most viewed videos of yours in the
most viewed moments in those videos
address one question do you have any
idea what it might be
no actually the biggest myths in
exercise right and I think you actually
pointed out one there with the um
Insight you got in Mexico the way we
exercise going to gyms practicing is the
natural or human but evidently it's
it's a consequence of the privilege of
our lives and the Comfort we have of not
having to seek out our dinner every day
what are some of the other biggest myths
within exercise that um you've come
across in writing this book gosh there
are so many I had to actually limit
limit it to ten so I think um if you
understand physical activity and
exercise you also have to understand
inactivity and I think one of the
biggest myths out there is that you need
eight hours of sleep a night and that
sitting is when you're smoking you know
that basically and I if you think about
those two different myths why is it that
we're constantly told to sleep more and
to sit less
actually it seems a little contradictory
to me right and it turns out that um
that let's take sitting first so
um you know there are all these uh you
know these slogans like sitting against
and you're smoking and it's really bad
for you and you know every time you sit
in your chair you lose two hours of your
life and whatever uh turns out that uh
all animals sit right my dog sits um
cows sit chickens sit every animal sits
and hunter gatherers also sit in fact if
you some of my students actually put
sensors on hunter-gatherers and uh when
we're doing some research in Farmers as
well but they sit just as much as
westerners
um uh so sitting is there's nothing
special about being uh about today's
life it's sitting so it's that we sit
all day long and don't do anything when
we're not sitting right so if you and
and furthermore the big distance
difference is not so much how much we
said but how how we sit so turns out
that people who
um if you get up every once in a while
right interrupted sitting is actually
much more healthy than non-interrupted
sitting okay
the same amount of time so in other
words two people might in the west
people sit for an average about 40
minutes at about whereas
hunter-gatherers for example are farmers
in Africa where we work get up every
about 10-15 minutes and when you do that
you actually it's like turning on the
engine of your car you don't drive it
around the block you're you're you're
you're
um you're turning on all kinds of
cellular mechanisms you lower blood
sugar levels your all kinds of genes get
activated and it turns out that that is
by far the most important way to way to
sit so just get up every once in a while
just pee frequently make a cup of tea
you know pet your dog whatever thinking
when I'm on planes and I've got a long
flight I always sit in the aisle right
so I can get up a lot always
and um what about sleep then so sleep is
another interesting one so this idea
that you know
um that you need eight hours of sleep
it's been around for a long time it's
been around basically since the
Industrial Revolution
um but um if you actually so so
colleagues in my field so an
evolutionary medicine have put sensors
on people who don't have
all the things that we're told have
destroyed sleep so think about it we're
told that TV and lights and and uh you
know our phones and all these things are
are preventing us from sleeping you know
Edison destroyed sleep right uh so so
when you put sensors on people who don't
have any electricity and they don't have
TVs and they don't have phones and they
don't have have any of these gadgetry
right electricity they it turns out they
sleep like six to seven hours a night
um and um they uh and they don't nap
um so this idea that natural human
beings sleep eight hours a night is just
it's just nonsense it's just not true
and furthermore when you start looking
at the data seven hours if you actually
look at if you graph sort of how many
hours a night you sleep on the x-axis
and sort of uh you know some outcome
like cardiovascular disease or just How
likely you are to die it's kind of a
U-shaped curve so people don't get much
sleep are in trouble but the bottom of
that curve is pretty much always about
seven hours so people actually do better
if they sleep seven hours rather than
eight hours and yet we're told that if
you don't sleep eight hours there's
something wrong right oh so you can
oversleep
well yeah I mean there's also some
complexity of this too because of course
people who are ill might be sleeping
more and so there's some there's some
biases that creep into the how you
analyze the data but but basically it
turns out that seven is for most people
optimal but there's a lot of variation
right you know teenagers sleep more
older people sleep less it's complicated
one of the things popular in culture as
well is this idea of doing 10 000 steps
a day yeah now that's fun you know that
started because of a Japanese epidemic
pedometer um so but right before the the
Olympics were in Tokyo in the in the 60s
they had invented the pedometer and they
were in the sitting in a board room and
they were discussing what to call the
pedometer and they picked out of just
out of the blue they picked 10 000 steps
because that's apparently an auspicious
number and it sounded about right there
was no science behind it interestingly
it turns out it's pretty good
um if you actually if you look at steps
per day
and health outcomes your average
hunter-gatherer walks between 10 to 18
000 steps depends on male or female Etc
and and if you look at steps per day and
and outcomes
um
but around seven to eight thousand steps
the curve kind of bottoms out right
there's it doesn't seem to be a huge
advantage to taking more than that per
day in terms of you know large
epidemiological studies so it turns out
to be not that bad a goal but it's not a
there's no
it's not a perfect number like a lot of
things right it's just a kind of a it's
a reasonable it's a reasonable goal to
shoot for
when you um when you started writing
this this book about exercise and
running on all these subject matters was
there any
instant changes or any real lasting
changes that you implemented into your
own life from everything you've learned
I think about that all the time with
this podcast I'll have a guest on I have
these mini Eureka moments and then
something will stick so I'm wondering
having studied all of these people all
around the world and looked at their
bodies and exercise and physical
exertion
what have you taken into your own life
that has stuck
I would say that I've become more
serious about doing some strength
training you know I've always loved
walking and running and you know
endurance kinds of activities and I've
always sort of hated doing weights you
know I just don't like it and I'm I'm a
wimp you know I'm not a very well I'm
not a very strong person and you know
people tend to do what they like right
you get reinforcement from it and the
more I study the importance of
resistance training and the more I study
the importance of doing weights
especially as you age
um The more I've
the more I started kicking myself for
for being uh being lazy about that so
now I try to do a good two strength
workouts out of every week at least and
uh and take it more seriously because
especially as you age loss of muscle
mass can be really debilitating there's
a
um the technical term for that is
sarcopenia Sarco is is the Greek word
for muscle and penia is loss of muscle
loss so as people get older they tend to
lose muscle and when you do that you
become frail and you lose functional
capacity and then that starts off a
vicious cycle right once that happens
then you'll be less likely to be
fiscally active and then of course when
you're less Physically Active your
muscles begin to waste away more and
it's very debilitating and so I think as
we get older and I'm getting older it's
more and more important you know to to
kind of incorporate that so I think
that's the one thing that I've I've
taken to Heart yeah from what you said
there it sounds like not doing
resistance training not doing not
lifting weights as you age almost
accelerates Aging in any sort of
superficial sense but but it also in a
physiological sense you're you're
increasing the speed of Aging yeah I'm
not sure if I'd think about it that way
but it I think I I kind of reverse it
slightly which is that
you know aging is just the clock ticking
on right there's nothing we can do about
age but senescence is the way the way
our bodies degrade as we get older and
what physical activity does affection
maybe the most important thing about
physical activity is that it slows
senescence especially for certain organs
and systems and there are different
kinds of physical activities so there's
endurance physical activities you know
like running walking Etc swimming and
then strength or resistance physical
activities and they have different kinds
of ways in which they slow various
properties of senescence which we you
know colloquially call aging and all of
them are important and I think one of
the things that's really interesting
about humans in fact I think it may be
the most important thing about this book
and you asked about myths earlier the
most important myth I think by far is
this idea that as you get older it's
normal to be less active and that is
just not true we evolved to be
grandparents we evolved to live one of
the things that's most interesting about
humans maybe is that we evolve to live
about 20 years or so after we stop
reproducing no other animal does that
except except orcas maybe killer whales
but with the exception of killer whales
humans have this really weird life
history we evolve to be grandparents but
grandparents in the old days weren't you
know
retiring to Florida or I don't know
where they do but they do in England or
whatever go to Majorca or whatever and
you know kick up their heels and play
golf or whatever with carts grandparents
in the in the olden days right or in
many cultures still today are working
right they're working in the fields
they're hunting they're Gathering
they're getting food for their children
and their grandchildren they're helping
with child care and that physical
activity
is you know that's what their job is to
be physically active but in turn that
physical activity turns on an amazing
Suite of of physiological processes that
counter aging turns on repair and
maintenance processes that not only keep
our muscles strong but also keep our DNA
from accruing mutations keep our
mitochondria numbers High keep keep our
the cells in our brain from accumulating
Gunk so that prevents Alzheimer's and
other forms of dementia I mean for
almost for every system of the body
physical activity has has benefits that
slow the aging process and so when you
stop doing it you accelerate and that's
the way in which you it perceive you
perceive it as accelerating aging but
really it's the absence of physical
activity which lets aging run a mark in
your first book in 2013 the story of the
human body in chapter 12 you said um
use this phrase you use it or lose it
basically we we evolve to use or lose
our bodies and I was sat with um someone
recently and I was trying to figure out
why it appears that when people retire
or the other instance I've seen is when
they're their elderly partner passes
away it appears as if they don't live
much longer yeah it's kind of like kind
of folklore or something that once you
retire
your days are kind of numbered yeah yeah
and I I was trying to figure out the
evolutionary reason for that but it
sounds like that's kind of what you've
explained there well I mean I think part
of that is um is depression right
um when you lose a partner I mean grief
and depression your cortisol levels go
up your immune system goes down I mean
you know it's it's really tough on your
body I mean psychosocial stress plays a
serious physiological toll but but also
as you just pointed out when people
retire they're become less active and
that that loss of activity
has enormous effects on every aspect of
our of our of our body I mean in our
brain and our minds I mean physical
activity is important not just for
physical health but also vital for
mental health and I think a lot of the
problems that a lot of mental health
issues we have today depression anxiety
uh some of them to some extent we can
attribute that to loss to less physical
activity and as people age
becoming less Physically Active again
makes them much more vulnerable to a
wide Suite of diseases
so would you say we shouldn't retire
well or if you do retire I mean retiring
is again another modern weird thing
right nobody retired in the past I mean
if you're a farmer it's like a
subsistence farmer and name it any place
right it's not like something you hit 65
and all of a sudden you no longer have
to work in the fields you work in the
fields until you're you know until
you're dead right and hunter-gatherers
don't retire they they continue to be
physically active until until they die
right or until they get too sick so it's
a very modern Western concept
um and um and yes we do pay a price for
it but you of course can replace
you know work that you do with with with
challenging rewarding fun things to do
the important thing is just not to not
to stop being Physically Active one of
my favorite studies ever published
without a doubt
um is a is a study done by a guy named
Ralph paffenbarger he realized that
places like Harvard are fantastic for
studying aging because
um Harvard like other private
universities never lets go of their
alumni
so until you the day you die they're
asking you for money on a regular basis
and and so they're um um and so he he
got the Alumni Association the Harvard
development office to let him follow a
series of Harvard alumni from several
years and can keep asking them
and questions about their physical
activity levels and also their diet and
whether they smoked and stuff like that
and then you track them for 25 30 years
and what he found was that the alumni we
have to correct it for every Factor you
could think of that as you as the alumni
got older the effect of physical
activity on their health outcomes was
bigger and bigger so alumni who are in
their 20s 30s and 40s for example who
were exercising you know four or five
times a week they had about 20 percent
lower death rates by the time they got
to their 60s and 70s the alumni who were
exercising more had 50 lower death rates
so as you get older
so what and this has been replicated
again many times but what he showed was
that as you get older exercise becomes
more not less important for maintaining
your health
been thinking a lot about this because I
was saying to Jack my dad is
60-ish but he's very very out of shape
very very out of shape and I was in um I
was in Indonesia and I was with my
girlfriend and we went and we were going
white water rafting so we had to go down
this really big hill
with all these stairs it was like 300
meters of stairs and I remember just
thinking my dad wouldn't be able to do
this at his age at 60 and I want to be
able to go down those stairs when I'm
his age because at the bottom there was
a fun activity with someone I loved and
to think that I'll get to a point in my
life where
not so far away in the grand scheme of
things um where I won't be able to go up
or down some stairs because I'm 60
um because of my sort of genetic
predisposition as I saw it was quite was
quite sad but having heard you say that
it really feels much more like a choice
than it is genetics yeah look we have
this expression in my field which is
that genes load the gun an environment
pulls the trigger right some of us have
genetic predispositions towards being
you know more likely to get diabetes or
heart disease or this or that or the
other but our great great grandparents
in different environments weren't
getting these diseases or they were
getting them at much much lower
frequencies it's not because they were
dying earlier it's because these
diseases were less common so I think we
too often blame our genes for many of
these these these diseases
um or many of these health problems um
and it's I'm not in any way denying the
role of genetics but that environment is
way more important and we have control
over our environment to some extent and
so if you want to reduce your risk of
cardiovascular disease reduce your risk
of diabetes reduce your risk of
Alzheimer's dementia
exercises in a Magic Bullet it's not
going to prevent you from getting those
diseases completely but it lowers your
risk
quite quite quite substantially and we
know why too I mean we have an immense
amount of data on why that's the case
for every single one of these diseases
we understand the mechanisms by which
physical activity has uh you know
important mechanistic effects on on
these diseases so it's this
epidemiological data there's mechanistic
data there's personal data the problem
is that it's hard to do right it's it
takes willpower to overcome the the the
inertia of of of of doing what's
completely normal which is wanting to
take it easy right I was I was just you
know I just flew yesterday from Denver
to Boston
and in the in the in the in the airport
you know there are these escalators
right next to the stairway right and and
and and and
um the escalator and the stair it wasn't
a huge stairway everybody's lining up to
take the escalator and like the stairs
are totally free so I being me I of
course I can't I'm not allowed to take
the escalator unless you know I have to
right so I run up the stairs but you
know it's but those people taking the
escalator there's nothing wrong with
them they're not lazy it's just an
instinct or it's an instinct to take to
take it easy when you can right because
and we now live in a world where
everybody can do that right because we
have escalators and and lifts and cars
and shopping carts and all these
wonderful devices
to make our lives easier and now you
have to overcome this fundamental Basic
Instinct to take it easy in order to be
physically active and that's basically
what exercise is
and so and furthermore if you're out of
if you're unfit and you're not really
you know exercising isn't any fun right
it's it's it's it's unpleasant you you
know you sweat and you get hot and you
get cranky and you know um and and it's
not that rewarding uh until you get fit
and so uh people hate it right
um and uh and then we blame them for
being lazy but they're actually just
being they're just being normal and I
think we need to have more compassion
towards towards people who struggle to
exercise quick one before we get back to
this episode just give me 30 seconds of
your time
two things I wanted to say the first
thing is a huge thank you for listening
and tuning in to the show week after
week means the world to all of us and
this really is a dream that we
absolutely never had and couldn't have
imagined getting to this place but
secondly it's a dream where we feel like
we're only just getting started and if
you enjoy what we do here please join
the 24 of people who watch this channel
regularly and have hit that subscribe
button means more than I can say and if
you hit that subscribe button here's a
promise I'm gonna make to you I'm gonna
do everything in my power to make this
show as good as I can now and into the
future we're going to deliver the guests
that you want me to speak to and we're
going to continue to keep doing all of
the things you love about the show
thank you thank you so much back to the
episode this Basic Instinct to take it
easy are we evolved to be lazy take
escalated Riders well I wouldn't use the
word lazy but we are evolved to take it
easy to to rest whenever possible right
so we've now got ourselves into a bit of
a comfort crisis here because everything
has in our lives is optimizing us for
convenience and ease right right and
well it's also it's it sells right I
mean Comfort I mean I mean who prefers
to sit in economy as opposed to business
class right nobody right Comfort is nice
right who prefers shoes that are
uncomfortable right we we you know
comforts comforts you know we love
Comfort right but since when is Comfort
necessarily better for you right I mean
our comfortable shoes actually better
for you than going Barefoot or the
comfortable chair is better for you than
we're taking the the lift better for you
than taking this it is a short term or
at least it appears to be today right
yes because we often value the
short-term benefit over the long-term
cost right
um that's hyperbolic discounting is the
technical term for that but but
um so we you know we live in a world
where where we we you know we pay extra
for for Comfort or and we'll prefer it
but um but now we also live in a world
where we have to now go out of our way
to be physically active because it's no
longer necessary and so again I go back
to my original statement which is that
people evolved to be physically active
for two reasons and two reasons only
when it's necessarily rewarding when we
don't make it necessary we need to
figure out ways to make it rewarding and
and that's hard it's very hard
making it rewarding so one way that you
might make something rewarding is by
looking at the stick and then the other
side is maybe the carrot but just
looking at the stick then you were going
through a series of diseases a second
ago Alzheimer's
um high blood pressure all of these
kinds of things cardiovascular diseases
I almost think we've come to assume that
these are inevitabilities of Life yeah
we'll get cancer yeah one of us will get
yeah someone in here is going to get
Alzheimer's and that's the way we live
so we're we're preparing to meditate
when that day comes that's right I get
good forbid diagnosed with something
that's absolutely right in fact that's
what medical students today are taught
right if you go to medical school today
you're taught that as people get older
their blood pressure goes up I can tell
you that's just not true it's in the
western world where people are
physically inactive and eat crap diets
that their blood pressure tends to go up
but there are plenty of people I'm
actually one of them right who don't
have high blood pressure as they age and
guess what's the best way to prevent
getting a high blood pressure as you age
it's um you know it's not like a broken
record but we have this idea that as you
get older yes you're are gonna you're
and we're lucky right you know because
we don't die from smallpox when we're
30. we're lucky to get cancer when we're
60 right what we've done is we've
confused diseases that are more common
with aging with age being a cause of
those diseases in the first place and
they're not inevitable inevitable
diseases and many of them are
preventable and and the problem is that
in our society we we don't value
prevention very much we may talk about
it but we don't really put our money
where our mouth is right in the U.S
which is arguably one of the worst
Healthcare Systems it is the worst
Healthcare System among the
industrialized Western World we spend
approximately three percent of our
budget our medical Budget on prevention
And yet when people walk into a doctor's
office 75 of the time the disease is
according to the Center for Disease
Control of preventable disease so we
essentially spend nothing to prevent
diseases that overwhelm our system and
cause enormous amounts of misery it's a
completely backwards due stupid system
and so and and the good news is it's not
that hard to prevent a lot of these
things
um it takes willpower and takes
education and it takes access to to good
quality food and whatever
um but um so in the one sense it's very
depressing on the other hand The
Optimist in me says you know we really
can do something and people even if
without even if they're not wealthy or
whatever I mean they're simple things
that everybody can do to improve their
health outcomes these diseases we we
encountered today as we age and just
generally in our society when you look
at hunter gatherer hunter-gatherer
communities where you look at certain
tribes around the world maybe in Africa
do you see the same
um
the same types of diseases in the same
occurrence level of occurrence or is
there some diseases which just don't
like I'm wondering if like if because
you know cancer seems to be so popular
for as the disease and Alzheimer's and
these kinds of things so I Wonder has
that always been the case throughout
human history and is that the case in
other parts of the world that's such a
good question so first of all some of
these some of these diseases are really
hard to to measure in non-western
populations because we don't have the
diagnostic tools so nobody really knows
how common cancer is in in a lot of
parts of the world right there's just
the data don't exist that said when you
make estimates and you do look at the
studies that are out there and even if
you look in in historical records and in
places like Europe where people have
been keeping track of this there is no
question that cancer rates have been
rising and that cancer rates are much
much more common in the western world
there's a strong association between
Cancer and wealth and that's because
cancer is basically a disease of energy
right when your cells because cancer is
basically natural selection gone awry in
the body it's when cells start competing
with each other either
in ways that that cause basically and
start you know going you know
multiplying and dividing out of control
right it's a kind of natural selection
and what is it that those cells are
doing they're competing for energy and
when you have more energy
like when you're eating more and being
less Physically Active
you can you basically feed those cells
so
um so cancer so a high levels of insulin
insulin is highly uh related to cancer
High insulin levels are carcinogenic
um high levels of a body of energy you
cause women for example to increase the
the amount of estrogen and progesterone
that they produce men produce more
testosterone these are and these are
these are hormones that of course are
for good for reproduction but they're
but again we have we evolve to be to
have as many babies as possible Right
but that doesn't mean that translates
into Health right so more estrogen more
progesterone increases risks of say
breast cancer or testosterone increases
the risk of prostate cancer so if you
look at most diseases right people are
more physically active they have lower
levels of estrogen progesterone
testosterone they have lower levels of
insulin they have lower levels of blood
sugar all of these depressed cancer
rates and on average people who are
Physically Active have much lower rates
of almost every single kind of cancer
that you can think of
women who walk 150 you know get 150
minutes of physical activity a week have
on average
about 30 to 50 lower lifetime breast
cancer risks than people who are
sedentary and yet for some reason this
is not a well-known fact
um and we underst we have we have
epidemiological data we have mechanistic
data we understand how and why it works
and yet and that how often do you hear
about cancer prevention we talk about
treating cancer which is all important
if I get cancer I would like it treated
too thank you very much but why don't we
spend more energy and activity and and
have more education about how to prevent
cancers in the first place
physical act I don't mean I've never had
that before so that's that's really
helped me um
to add more value to exercise in my mind
you're talking there about insulin
levels and how that has there's
a link between your insulin levels and
your chances of getting cancer
sugar
glucose
inflammation
bad
yeah I mean I mean look if you want to
if you want to take like the three
things you should you know if you really
care about your health don't smoke right
that's kind of obvious I think everybody
knows that
get some exercise I don't think you need
me to tell you that right and and cut
down on sugar and foods that are high in
sugar and low in fiber right that you
know what we call high glycemic foods
those are the foods that elevate your
your your your blood glucose levels your
your insulin levels shoot up and Insulin
insulin the basic function of insulin is
is it's what we call an anabolic hormone
it's its job is to is to store energy
glucose
glucose but also fat okay all right okay
so what insulin does is to get energy
into cells so it's like a taxi
it's like an Uber it's like a taxi yeah
well I mean it it's not attack it's like
a it's telling other cells to do that so
insulin for example binds to other cells
that are the actual taxis so it's like
it's like calling the Uber I would I can
maybe right
um and um and insulin is is you know
it's the fundam so when you when you eat
food insulin levels go up because its
job is to store that energy and when you
exercise insulin levels go down because
because you want to then use that energy
right so so uh so when cells get more
energy they're more prone to going out
of control basically and and and and
inflammation is caused by
basically by getting you store so much
fat in your cells that those fat cells
start to swell and when those starts to
swell like anything right they start to
rupture they get damaged and that damage
attracts the immune system and the
immune system gets turned on and that
causes inflammation so so too much
adiposity too much fats you know over
swollen fat cells is the is a primary
cause of systemic inflammation and
inflammation is like the slow burn in
our bodies that causes widespread damage
to pretty much everything you can think
of and it turns out that so the two ways
to deal with inflammation are one to
prevent it right so don't eat foods that
are pro-inflammatory like
anything with a lot of sugar basically
right I mean that you know the sugar is
highly inflammatory
um or trans fats are highly inflammatory
but also turns out many people don't
know this but you also want to turn down
your immune system right you want to
turn the dial down and I don't know just
give you one guess what it is that does
that exercise exercise and the and and
the way it does that is that when you
when you're physically active you're
using your muscle cells it turns out
muscles are also an endocrine organ your
muscles are producing a molecule called
interleukin-6 il-6 that in low levels is
pro-inflammatory but at high levels it's
actually anti-inflammatory it turns down
inflammation and your muscles because a
third of your body is muscle right when
you go for a run or or swim or bike ride
or whatever you're producing a ton of
this stuff and it turns down levels of
information so people are Physically
Active even if they're overweight are
actually controlling and regulating
their inflammation we never evolved to
regulate inflammation because in this
way because we never evolved to be
physically inactive until recently
nobody was physically inactive until
unless they were dying right so so so we
never evolved an alternative mechanism
to regulator inflammation other than
physical activity
and we didn't live in a world with this
much sugar we never lived in a way I
mean it's astonishing you pay more money
for Foods today that have less sugar
added right I mean that's just
ridiculous right because it's so cheap
and sugar is you know we love everybody
loves sugar I mean I've um I've gone
hunting with um hunter-gatherers you
know you know foreign and
um and I can tell you that they're honey
addicts right I mean I've gone out with
these guys and they go from you know if
they if they fail on their hunt like by
10 or 11 if you haven't killed an animal
you know that's it for the day right and
then it comes it turns from being a
Hunting Expedition to a honey collecting
Expedition and they'll go from hive to
Hive to Hive get smoke burn out the bees
and just Gorge themselves on more honey
than I could possibly imagine to eat
except these are a lean Physically
Active hunter-gatherers and they they
handle it just fine
um but it's you know it's the it's the
Paleolithic equivalent of you know
eating Mars Bars all day long but
they've been out doing physical activity
for how long yeah I mean the average day
is about 15 kilometers of of walking
with some running yeah so so so they're
you know they can they can they can cope
with it how many hours is that
oh that's two to three hours probably
okay so from that I have garnered that I
need to do 15 kilometers a day
for two or three hours every day well
remember it's not a prescription right
so that's a kind of like the Paleo
fantasy sort of naturalistic fantasy
that if you live like a hunter-gatherer
somehow your your world will be perfect
right that's basically what the paleo
diet is sort of all about right and
that's not true either
yes we need to be physically active but
it turns out that a certain amount you
know if you're any any physical activity
is better than none right and if you
look at the kind of any curve of any
output any health health outcome like
how many years you live or whether
you're likely to get cancer or heart
disease or whatever you know any little
physical activity your curve starts to
fall quickly right your likelihood of
cardiovascular disease that's just you
know a few minutes a day of exercise has
big benefits but eventually that curve
flattens out right and it flattens out
well before the hunter-gatherer level so
you don't need to be a hunter-gatherer
in terms of physical activity to get the
benefits
this is a I've asked a few people this
question I don't think everyone's
anyone's really answered it um but I
suspect you might be able to if if you
were responsible for redesigning the
nature of our modern world to make it
more matched and less mismatched what
are some of the first things you would
do to help Society benefit in terms of
our happiness and our health
I I think about this all the time
because we don't seem to be turning
around we seem to be hurtling in a
direction kind of unconsciously towards
artificial intelligence and moving less
and being more sedentary and taking
pills more to fix everything
lonelier than ever before
you know if we were to redesign it blank
canvas piece of paper
that's a tough question because
um
we've essentially given
ourselves what we want right I can go
into a supermarket and
I mean I can do something that's
unimaginable until recently I can have I
can have basically anything I can eat
better than the king of France you know
a few Generations ago I can I can I mean
here I can New York there's like every
Cuisine possibly available to me I I
don't ever have to climb the stairs I
can take elevators I mean we've we've
we've we've made our world
so convenient and comfortable and yet
there are consequences to the many of
the things that we crave and want
so
in an Ideal World you don't want to you
don't want to REM I mean you have to you
have to honor and respect people's
um um desires right I'm not a I don't
believe in in preventing people from
taking the elevator right or or forcing
them to you know eat eat a whole grain
bread as opposed to white bread right
but if you banned white bread and you
banned elevators other than for those
people that need it for accessibility
reasons Etc they would do better over
the long term they would be healthy and
happier they would right so it's really
a balancing act between between
um
um respecting people's Liberties and
choices and educating them and helping
them so in my world I would I would do
more to nudge people right
um I would instead of banning sugar I
would tax it more
um instead of
um
pushing uh all kinds of foods on people
I would push I mean why don't we why
don't we advertise healthy foods the way
we advertise unhealthy Foods right I
mean when's the last time you saw an ad
for just how amazingly healthy asparagus
was right but that doesn't get the part
of my brain
going does it no it doesn't but um but
we could do more to to nudge and
encourage and help people right you
don't have to like ban sugar and cookies
right otherwise some people but but but
simply promote
um and help people help themselves right
most people want to eat healthier food
most people want to exercise
um but they live in a world where it's
hard to do it and they live in a world
where
um there are very few incentives I would
make it such that healthy food would be
as as inexpensive as as unhealthy food
and make sure that that people had
incentives and and make it also fun to
be physically active like for example
um
every I mean who doesn't like to dance
right every culture in the world has
dancing right dancing is a form of of
physical activity it's social it's fun
it's engaging why don't we have uh why
doesn't every every town in America
sponsor dancing
right
um you know it would probably do an
enormous amount for people's physical
health and their mental health I mean we
could do that I mean that's just one
example right so I would I would um I
would I would I would and and why is it
that in medical schools doctors don't
learn about I mean they don't they don't
study nutrition and they don't don't
study exercise and they don't learn
um because that's because in our medical
system is designed to treat people after
they get sick rather than prevent people
from getting sick so so we need to you
know reverse how we fund health care
right and so schools of Public Health
are these kind of little marginalized
places where you know where where great
ideas go to die right and and medical
schools where all the money is right and
doctors aren't
I mean their entire fields of medicine
that don't have the word preventive
associated with them I mean you've ever
heard of preventive Orthodontics or
preventive uh you know Optometry or
preventing you know the preventive
Orthopedics I mean it just doesn't exist
right so we we could do a lot more
um and and have enormous benefits
chapter 11 of this book you talk about
someone who has taken their own approach
to getting people moving and exercising
um in their own business that's the
bjornberg company I love that Bjorn ball
company can you tell me about that yeah
so I was um
so I was I was curious about this idea
of how to get how to help people be more
physically active right and again
you know my my fundamental hypothesis is
that we evolved to be physically active
either when it's necessary or rewarding
and so I was curious if there's any any
companies in the world that have made
physical activity necessary in other
words what if we force people to be
physically active and I found one so far
I think there's only one company in the
world that I know of maybe there's some
others but this is the only one I've
ever found so far and it's the bjornborg
sports company in Sweden where the CEO
of the company is this crazy sort of
exercise addict and he um he requires
every member of the company to to
exercise they have sports hour every
Friday at 11 o'clock so I actually
um when I when I was searching around
and I was thinking you know I write
working on the book I actually you know
got I found an article about them and I
you know I clicked on the on the company
website
and you know how every most companies
have a little contact us so I I clicked
on the contact desk and I wrote a little
note saying you know dear bjornberg
company I'm a researcher an evolutionary
biologist I'm interested in exercise and
I'm and I'm fascinated by how your
company requires people to exercise can
I learn more and the next morning there
was a an email from the CEO of the
company saying why don't you come and
visit us so so I hopped on a plane a few
a few months later went to Sweden and
they they let me he was so nice he just
let me just go anywhere in the company
and I went to sports Tower and I I
talked to employees throughout the
company and it was fascinating I mean um
a lot of the employees of the company
first of all a bunch of people
apparently left the company when he took
over a CEO and required this but it
doesn't matter who you are you could be
working in the mail room you could be
the CEO you could be a visiting board
member whoever you are if you're there
on Friday you have to go exercise with
them and they have this pretty serious
kind of exercise thing and apparently
some people quit but
um but but pretty much everybody else
said you know it's actually a pretty
damn good thing do you agree with that
approach well yes and no
um every University in the world used to
require in every school right supposedly
requires exercise right I'm sure you had
physical exercise you know physical some
kind of phys Ed required in your school
those standards are slipping around the
world and more and more kids are doing
less and less in school
universities were no exception it used
to be that all universities required
some degree of physical education mine
was no exception in fact Harvard was a
leader in that back in the you know 100
something years ago
and over the uh since basically the
1970s that's basically disappeared
although most students if you ask them
they think yeah it's actually a pretty
good idea so I don't know maybe we can
bring back exercise as a and and the
thing is that if you get used to it
right when you're young you're more
likely to do it when you're older right
because you set those are the that's the
age in which your habits become become
about your habits become your habits
right and so at this a certain age where
where if you can keep keep you know get
that making it make it a habit you're
probably more likely to continue doing
it for the rest of your life we kind of
see it as overreach don't we I was
thinking about if I was to announce one
of my companies that everyone is now
required to exercise it would seem like
like tremendous overreach if I announce
that everyone is required to read a
certain book they do it it'll be fine
and it might be seen as a positive thing
right it might be a representation of
our values that we are Learners and
we're innovators and we keep you know
nourishing our brains but we turn around
to your team and said this thing we're
all acquired to you're all required to
go for a run every day or something
people would it just feels personal yeah
like that's not the responsibility of an
organization to tell me
to go for exercise but we have we have
company you know Retreats I mean we do
all kinds of stuff where people are
required to do it so I don't know I
challenge you try it what we do and what
we've always done we even do it with
this team the driver SEO team is about
30 people so we have a fitness channel
in the company
um slack channel the communication
channel that we use and in that channel
um and we did this at my previous
company as well where we would
enable and facilitate so we
someone started a women's football team
so we enabled it and promoted it someone
started a men's football team so we
enabled it and promoted it and this this
also applies to non-physical sort of
exercise related clubs like someone
starts the reading club and we enabled
it and promoted it
um and we also paid for it if they need
to if they need new kits for example
when the women's football team needed
wanted to have their own uniforms we
paid for it because we saw a huge value
in terms of Staff retention connection
community and all those things that
actually lead up to staff retention
if we could have more Social Clubs
outside of the office you know if you're
thinking about leaving a job there's a
number of things you weigh up to pay the
job whatever but you also weigh up how
the community like the group of people I
love and how much they bring to my life
and I actually think in the remote
Working World
um it's something that CEOs and leaders
have really not paid enough attention to
that if they really want to retain their
team members they should have them
together as much as they can even
outside of the office bonding in a world
where screens are on the rise and pubs
are on the decline in social activities
and churches are on the decline there's
less sort of Institutions that connect
to socially work has a big opportunity
to do to do that so one of my big things
always in my head is like how can I get
the team members and my companies to
hang out more and a multiplier to that
is how can I get them to hang out more
and move their bodies more because then
they'll feel better right well well
think about it it's play right play yeah
exactly and I mean and play is what is
another thing we evolve to do right like
kids play and we're one of the few
species that plays as adults right and
what is play play is a way in which you
you learn cooperation you you you build
community but you also move your body
right
in the first chapter of your book you
say that you went to visit the Native
American tribe and I'm going to try and
pronounce this the Tara Huma Tara humara
and they're famous for their long
running yes what did you learn about
running from them
well it's you know they have been famous
for well over 100 years I mean many uh
people have gone to study the taramara
and have commented on their amazing
ability to run but what I really learned
from them is that
um for them physical activity is
spiritual
um you know there's this book Born to
Run that uh that describes their their
running and calls them a hidden tribe of
Supernatural super athletes they're not
hidden and they're not super athletes
um and um and the one thing that the
book missed was that the the main
impetus for the for their for the
running they do these famous
long-distance races is that it's a form
of Prayer
it's really very beautiful
um and um and it's a it's a metaphor for
for life and um and and it's also a an
opportunity to bet in sports and all
that it's all wrapped into one and and
what I've learned was that this actually
used to be
almost Universal among Native American
populations right Native American tribes
everybody had long distance races and
ball games and and they were all had a
spiritual element it's just that
they've they've retained their
traditions because they're in a very
remote
part of of Mexico that's essentially
inaccessible we all used to do this all
humans used to do this and in fact if
you think if you look around the world
every population has this tradition of
endurance during its events
some of the subject might you talk about
in your book but also outside of your
book is is how we used to run
um in terms of you know I was at the
foot doctor
what's it called I don't know what
they're called podiatrist that's what I
said but podiatrist what did I say but I
went to the podiatrist the other day
because I
I got this what's it called when you're
I'm gonna point it on my foot it's part
of my foot here started to get lots of
pain everything that's it plantar
officiitis I started to get some plantar
fasciitis and it was just this ongoing
pain and they prescribed me some insoles
I stood on a couple of machines some
soft stuff and they measured my foot and
took this scan of it and said right
basically you're standing wrong
um your arch is a bit too flat take
these insoles and wear them in all of
your shoes and I just I always think in
these moments when someone prescribes me
something that's not natural I go
why like where did I go wrong
and I think that's the key question
where did I go wrong who lied to me
to the point now that at 30 years old I
have these bloody insoles that I have to
put in all my shoes because presumably
that's not natural presumably my my
ancestors don't have Bloody insoles yeah
so
plantar fasciitis is what I would call a
mismatch disease right a disease that's
more common or more severe because our
bodies are inadequately adapted to
Modern environments and in your case and
as is the case with a lot of people you
have a weak foot so so we you know you
look like you go to the gym looks like
you're a pretty fit person right I'll
make a bet you you strengthen pretty
much every muscle group in your body
except your feet right no come on right
well but we don't right one of the
reasons is because we we encase our feet
in stiff-sold shoes that are very
comfortable and and the reason the shoes
are comfortable is that your your foot
muscles have to do less work when you
was using those shoes right we have
shoes that are stiff soles they have
arch supports right and your foot has
four layers of muscles in them and those
muscles are supporting your arch and at
the bottom of those four layers of
muscles is this layer of connective
tissue the plantar fascia and the
problem with the plantar fascia is that
if it stretches too much it like
anything else right it gets inflamed but
it's got almost no vascularization right
so it's very hard for it to repair
itself when it gets inflamed to prevent
plaster plantar fasciitis the best way
to preventing it is having a strong foot
a strong foot's a healthy foot so the
way to the way to treat the disease on
the long term is to strengthen your foot
but if you want to just alleviate the
symptoms that's what your podiatrist did
by giving you an insole right it's
basically
preventing your muscle your arch from
collapsing as much making it more
comfortable so your your plantar fascia
gets stress less and so it can kind of
alleviates that that that that that
stretching and hence the pain right so
that's a typical example of what I call
dis Evolution it's what what happens
when you treat the symptoms of a
mismatched disease rather than their
causes of preventing their causes so
podiatrists are a bit like drug pushers
in that sense right because they're
they're essentially putting your foot in
a cast right and then and for the rest
of your life you kind of have to keep
using them unless you strengthen your
feet so I so so there's nothing wrong
with those you know treating the
symptoms I mean pain is no fun so where
are the insoles right to kind of you
know alleviate the pain but also work on
strengthening your foot and I think
you'll find that the plantar fasciitis
will will disappear and never come back
so the plantar fasciitis fasciitis um
has now healed
after about a month of wearing the
insole
um I no longer have the insoles um with
me here in New York and I don't have
them in any of my shoes because I've
also taken a bit of time off
um running on my feet I was playing a
lot of football
so now I'm at a point where I can go to
the preventable stage prevent it
happening again and you said to
strengthen my foot how does one
strengthen their foot
good question so there are some
exercises and they're kind of foot
doming exercises and things like that
they're you know I can send you some
links to videos showing you some good
foot strengthening exercises so that's
one way to do it but the other way is to
wear more minimal shoes to wear shoes
that aren't stiff sold that don't have
arch supports go barefoot a lot right
and those that will naturally strengthen
the muscles in your foot because you'll
have to use those muscles so you ever
gone for like a long walk or run on a
beach right and afterwards your your
feet are kind of tired right the reason
your feet are tired is because you're
now working on a compliant surface right
it's not stiff so your muscles having to
work more
to stiffen your foot to push you forward
right jack could you go grab my the
black shoe out of my bag I just want to
show him something so uh so wearing
shoes that aren't as stiff sold when
they don't have arch supports will
slowly strengthen your feet but and this
is a huge but if you do too much too
fast you will your plantar fasciates
will come roaring back and you'll hate
me you'll like you'll never forgive me
because
um yeah there's a Vivo barefoots
um yeah I wear the same shoes oh you've
got the same shoes on
um great shoes yeah those are wonderful
shoes those are those are the those are
the exactly the kind of shoes that will
help strengthen your feet these are
failing a new addition in my life yeah
yeah they and they feel really strange
because you can kind of feel the floor
yeah it's exactly what you've described
is yeah but but you you can transition
if you have a weak feet which I'm
guessing you do you if you go if you
suddenly if that's the only shoe you
wear all the time you'll probably regret
it right so so slowly slowly slowly
increase the percentage of time that
just like anything else if you if you
like suddenly decide to lift you know
huge weights that you can't lift before
you'll hurt yourself right the same
thing is with your feet so so slowly it
does it but you if you do it gradually
and slowly and carefully you can build
up strength in your foot and um and
you'll and you'll be a happier happier
person and this is this goes back to
everything else you've said about how
choosing Comfort choosing to have a nice
supportive shoe has actually just kind
of deferred a problem off into the
future for me it's the same with diets
the same with avoiding exercise and
being sanitary and and all these other
things where when you choose the easy
Road in the short term which is this
wonderful cushioned shoe I've chosen the
muscle hasn't built up in my foot and
I've paid the price correct so I need to
again choose discomfort more in the
short term go up the stairs run Barefoot
to avoid the late the consequences later
down the line yeah I mean I don't think
you have to run Barefoot but um though
it can be fun but um
um but yeah I mean and I can think of
plenty of other examples
um we love Comfort but comfort's not
necessarily good for us
when you um when you look at these
tribes are they do you know who liver
King is huge massive muscles talks about
ancestral living
um what do our hunter-gatherer ancestors
look like in terms of them not like him
no okay I mean look think about it
muscle is really expensive right it's
actually a super expensive tissue about
a third of our body is muscle and it's
using up about about you know A fifth or
more of the calories that we're
expending right uh just just sitting
there not even using them right they're
they're very costly tissues right and so
if you have more muscle than you need
you're basically
adding to your your cost of living right
if you're if you're a hunter-gatherer or
even a subsistence farmer living on the
margin of food security having more
muscle than you need is actually
deleterious right remember the only
thing that natural selection cares about
is how many offspring you have we
survive and reproduce it doesn't care if
you're strong or healthy or nice or
loved or you know fun or whatever it
only cares about whether you have
grandchildren that's it right that's
that's cold calculus of selection my
brain is going if I have big muscles
I'll have more romantic opportunities
and then I'll have grandchildren well
only up to a certain point right now so
if more muscles if if they attract the
opposite sex and and make them want to
reproduce with you yes that could be a
benefit
I'm not so sure how much women are
attracted to the liver King but um and
that's not something I even want to know
the answer to but um and certainly
shouldn't ask him but um
um
um but but there's a reason we have use
it or lose it which you mentioned
earlier right because
when we need when we increase our demand
we increase our capacity right when you
go to the gym and you work out right you
build muscle but if you stop using those
muscles you lose it and that's an
adaptation right because you don't want
to spend extra energy on muscles you're
not using right so you want enough but
not too much you want to be economical
with muscle mass right um and so our if
you look at the data from
hunter-gatherers and people have done
that they've done grip strength tests
Etc and all kinds of other fun things
with like mini Olympics I mean we've
done this too
um people are reasonably strong but
they're not super strong and they're not
they're not buff and built and bulked
and all that sort of stuff they've got
enough muscle to do what they need to do
but no more
and the reason why people find muscle
attractive anyway is because it's
evolutionary signal isn't it of
uh reproductive value and resources
maybe and the ability to go out and you
know what I mean why why does why does a
woman for example find a man with
muscles or in good shape attractive in
2023 when we're not hunting for gazelle
well I'm not a I'm not a I'm not a
psychologist or or so I'm not sure if
I'm qualified to answer that but I could
I could Venture the guest that obviously
if you're trying to if you know we pair
bond as a species and we have been for
for millions of years probably you want
to pair bond with somebody who's going
to because we also have of cooperation
and food sharing right you want to pair
bond with somebody who's gonna be able
to you know bring home the bacon
literally and figuratively right but but
bringing home the bacon does not mean
looking like Arnold Schwarzenegger at
least back in the day Arnold
Schwarzenegger back in the day right
being bringing home the bacon back in
the day meant being a persistence Hunter
being able to run long distances and
being moderately strong so they looked
more like a marathoner or or a football
player than they did a a weight lifter
right so it's conceivable it's
conceivable that someone who is really
really big is actually
um less attractive because they wouldn't
have been able to hunt and run and Hunt
as well as someone who was a little bit
Yeah you also have to you have to feed
my you have to feed them more too yeah
and that's a you know those are precious
calories so I'm gonna guess that uh look
if you look in in non-western
populations uh you don't see physiques
like that this is a this is a privilege
of people who are able to go to gyms and
um and you know eat you know
you know whey powder shakes and all that
kind of stuff to kind of build their
crazy muscle mass but it's not something
that our ancestors were able to do on a
regular basis that's for sure a quick
quote on huel as you know they're a
sponsor of this podcast and I'm an
investor in the company one of the
things I've never really explained is
how I came to have a relationship with
Hugh one day in the office many years
ago a guy walked past called Michael and
he was wearing a heeled t-shirt and I
was really compelled by the logo I just
thought from a design aesthetic point of
view it was really interesting and I
asked him what that word meant and why
he was wearing that T-shirt and he said
it's this brand called heal and they
make food that is nutritionally complete
and very very convenient and has the
planet in mind and he the next day
dropped off a little bottle of fuel on
my desk and from that day onwards I
completely got it because I'm someone
that cares tremendously about having a
nutritionally complete diet but
sometimes because of the way my life is
that falls by the wayside so if there
was a really convenient reliable
trustworthy way for me to be
nutritionally complete in an affordable
away I was all ears especially if it's a
way that is conscious of the planet give
it a chance give it a shot let me know
what you think
there's another myth that are you bust
which I thought was really interesting
because I think I know a lot of people
that have used this as a reason not to
run they say it's really bad for your
knees oh man that gets me so mad right I
mean I hear this from doctors all the
time right oh yeah writing is bad for
your knees now it is true
that knee injuries are the most common
running injuries
um but
arthritis which is really what they're
usually talking about it's absolutely
definitively not true that running
increases rates of knee cartilage damage
and arthritis so arthritis is caused by
cartilage wearing away in a joint right
and it's a it's a myth that that running
actually increases cartilage damage if
you have arthritis running is
excruciating and problematic but if you
don't have it running actually if
anything may be slightly preventive
because
cartilage joints like everything else
benefits from being used right and so
physical activity actually helps promote
strong and healthy joints we used to
think that it just caused them to wear
away but actually you know like cars you
know wearing away at their tires but now
we know that actually physical activity
promotes repair mechanisms and cartilage
just as it does in other tissues in the
body
and um
and of course the other thing about
running is that I think a lot of people
run incorrectly today so uh so that's
why we started studying barefoot running
Millions you know along a few a bunch of
few decades ago is because if humans
have been running for millions of years
most of that time we were running
Barefoot so we're kind of curious how
did people run before shoes and what we
learned was that today shoes have these
cushioned heels
that enable you to essentially run the
way you walk right you land on your heel
and everybody who's Barefoot sometimes
lands on their heel but people who are
Barefoot often more often than not land
on the ball of their foot and then let
their heel down it's called a forefoot
strike or a midfoot strike
and when you do that we worked out the
biomechanics of that and published a
paper on the cover of nature showing
that when you do that you actually
prevent your foot from crashing into the
ground causing it what's called an
impact a collisional force you run
lightly and gently so if you were to
take your shoes off and run up
Lexington Avenue here
I guarantee you you would not be landing
on your heels within a few steps you'd
start landing on the ball of your foot
because it hurts less and so that's how
we evolve to run we've off to run in a
cushion in a way that that doesn't
involve
you know
he's slamming into the ground with every
step
and the and that that causes less Force
around your knee
um the trade-off though because nothing
comes for free everything has trade-offs
is that it's harder on your ankles your
calf muscles and your Achilles have to
do now a lot more work to let your heel
down and so people who switch from heel
striking to forefoot striking often have
Achilles tendon problems they get calf
muscle problems they don't do it
properly they'll get their foot muscles
aren't strong enough they'll get all
kinds of foot problems right so you
can't just suddenly become a Barefoot
Runner and start forefoot striking if
you're gonna switch you have to switch
gradually and slowly and build up
strength and learn to do it properly
another thing people do is they tend to
run like a ballerina high up on their
toes that's really hard on your ankles
and your calves so you got to do it
properly but if you but it can have
enormous benefits and so and we know
again if you run that way there's puts
much less force on your knees and again
knees are where people get injured the
most so I think a lot of knee injuries
come from
um
from the way in which we run
so would you recommend if you can to run
more
Barefoot especially if you have those
kind of shoes we just discussed well I
think what matters is how you run what's
on your feet okay so I would say a
Barefoot style how do I learn to run in
a new way though
well I mean there's some tricks so one
of them is
um first of all I don't know how you run
so so maybe maybe you already run just
fine
um but a Barefoot style tends to be a
high stride rate or high stride
frequency so 90 strides per minute or
180 steps per minute roughly
you know um 170 180 steps a minute is
about right
um relatively short strides so you're
not throwing your leg out and to me the
most important thing is not what we call
over striding you've asked any coach on
the planet they'll say overstriding is
bad over strings when you throw your leg
out way in front of you and you land and
that leg is a stiff leg so that a stiff
leg means more Force right
um and uh and um and it's harder on your
knees
um and so if you and so a good runner
lands uh with their with their shank
with their tibia vertical so their ankle
is below their knee when you do that
pretty much everything will work out
properly right
um it'll mean that you won't land hard
on your heel it'll mean that your your
leg will be acting like an excellent
spring you won't produce a lot of
braking Force
um it's a it's a it's I to me I think
the most important skill in running is
not to over stride
um and um so I actually so don't worry
about how you're going to hit the ground
just worry about your overstride if you
solve your overstride you're more likely
to run well what do you think's um
what's the best kind of sort of
cardiovascular exercise for the
promotion of good health because I've
been doing some CrossFit stuff I've been
doing some hit workouts
um I've been trying not to run because
I've had a few injuries and try not to
run as much because it seems to be a
little bit more impact than if I'm
bullshitting myself there but um so I've
been doing some like hit workouts every
for 30 minutes a day when I leave here
well you do it you hit it works every
single day pretty much every day at the
moment we track it with a group of
friends we have there's 10 of us in a
WhatsApp group whoever's last whoever
does the least workouts every month is
evicted and there's a raffle so there's
a raffle yesterday on the first was it
the first yesterday yeah for a new
member and we do that every month and
we've done it for three and a half years
that's good I've been in there I was the
first ever member so I've been in there
for three and a half years
well I think you know I mean the most
the best exercise the one you like doing
but is that one that's like better you
know like the you know I think you got
to mix it up there is no one perfect
exercise right I mean I think what you
do it sounds actually pretty good right
you got a mixture of of of you know low
slow intensity some some high intensity
you want to have some strength training
you want to have some cardio I mean we
never evolved to do one thing and our
bodies are too complex to benefit from
just one thing
uh mixing it up is is the obvious way to
go right um I think the Bedrock for any
kind of physical I mean you've asked
anybody right cardio is the Bedrock of
of of of of of of of exercise right it
it promotes the most health benefits
right and it's good for your good you
know your burning energy it's good for
your cardiovascular system it's good for
controlling inflammation but but but
there are different kinds of cardio in
high intensity versus low intensity and
there's also strength training right uh
which is also you know important so you
know there's no look we've tried to
medicalize exercise right it's like a
like there's a proper dose right you
know take this pill this many milligrams
this many times per week right exercise
it doesn't work that way there is no
there is no optimal dose everybody's
different it depends on are you more
worried about heart disease or
Alzheimer's or diabetes or depression or
you know are you previously injured are
you fit are you unfit there's it's
impossible to prescribe exercise in this
kind of medicalized way it doesn't work
a lot of people exercise because they
believe it will help them to lose fat
belly fat are the biggest debates on the
planet it has been a huge debate even on
this podcast I've had multiple people
come and say a whole range of things
about weight loss and cardio and I'm
kind of I don't know what to believe
anymore
well anybody wasn't confused doesn't
understand what's going on right you
know it's um
it's sad that it's such a debate
um but um but that's how science works
right so
um
as you know I wrote about that in this
book
um
part of the explanation for the debate
is that again
what dose are you analyzing and what
population in what kind of context right
so though pretty much every major Health
Organization in the world recommends
that you get 150 minutes per week of
physical activity that's kind of like
The Benchmark that's what the you know
the wh who the World Health Organization
considers the the division between being
sedentary versus active
so and a lot of people are unfit and
overweight and struggling to be
physically active have struggled to get
150 minutes a week right so a lot of
studies
prescribe 150 minutes a week of exercise
walking for example a moderate intensity
physical activity and then look at its
effects on weight loss and guess what
when you when you walk 150 minutes a
week which is what 20 minutes a day of
walking which is about a mile a mile a
day
you're not going to lose much weight
you're basically burning about 50
calories a day doing that right that's a
piddling amount of calories compared to
drinking a glass of orange juice right
so so surprise surprise those kinds of
studies show that
those doses of physical activity are not
very effective for weight loss
however plenty of rigorous controlled
studies that look at higher doses of
physical activity 300 minutes a week or
more find that they are effective at
losing for helping people lose weight
but not fast and not large quantities so
you're never going to lose a lot of
weight really fast by exercising
it's not going to happen because you
know a cheeseburger has what you know
800 900 calories you have to run
you know 15 kilometers to lose that to
burn the same number of calories you're
going to be hungry afterwards too so
you're going to make some of that back
you have compensation
so so physical activity is a is actually
there's just no way around it you have
to be a flat earther not to argue this
way but they're you know their physical
activity can help you lose weight but
it's not going to help you lose a lot of
weight fast and not at the low doses
that often are prescribed but the one
thing that we do agree on and I think
this would not be controversial is that
physical activity is really important
for helping people prevent themselves
from gaining weight or after a diet from
regaining weight and there are many many
studies which show this one of my
favorite was a study that was done in
Boston on policemen you know policemen
are kind of a reputation for you know
having too many donuts and being
overweight right and Boston is no
exception so they did this great study
at Boston University right across across
the river
where they got a bunch of policemen on a
diet
a really severe diet the policemen all
lost weight but some of the policemen
were had to diet and exercise some just
dieted alone and as you might imagine
the ones who died plus exercise lost a
little bit more weight not a lot just a
little but and then they tracked them
for months afterwards because most
people after a diet the weight comes
just crashing back right the policeman
who's kept exercising even after the
diet was over and they went back to
eating whatever the hell they wanted
donuts whatever they're the ones who
kept the weight off but the ones who
didn't exercise
the way it came crashing back another
good example would be the have you ever
seen the TV show The Biggest Loser uh
yes were they are people going to lose
weight yeah so that so there's a crazy
show right these people you know this is
like totally unhealthy they were
confined to a Ranch in Malibu and he's
got these people lost ridiculous amounts
of weight a guy named um Kevin Hall at
the National Institute of Health studied
them from for for years afterwards and
looked at and most of them regained a
lot of the weight that they lost and
there was one person on the show who did
not and that was the person who kept
exercising right and that's you know
just yet more we said one data point but
there's lots and lots of evidence to
show that physical activity what its
other important benefit when it comes to
weight is is preventing weight gain or
weight regain when we talk about dieting
we talk about exercise or Diet exercise
or Diet like why is it an or
I mean why isn't it exercise and diet
diet is of course the Bedrock for weight
loss but exercise also plays an
important role and should be part of the
mix
on the um police example and The Biggest
Loser example I
can relate in the sense that when I
exercise
when I go through the moments of my life
where I'm most committed to exercise I'm
also most committed to my diet yeah
because I if I go to the gym I will not
then leave the gym
and have a donut or a pizza absolutely
not it seems like wasting the effort so
if you look at the sort of correlation
between the moments in my life where I
eat healthiest they're also the moments
in my life where I'm most most focused
on the gym and I noticed there was a
couple of months ago I had a bit of a
motivation slump managed to stay in a
little WhatsApp group but
coaster down the bottom of the
leaderboard for a couple of months on a
just like surviving every month by one
um and through those moments my
motivation of the gym had gone down and
my diet had gone down the minute I
managed to get in the gym and do a big
workout
the same day my diet came back yeah of
course right and they co-vary right and
and that's one of the reasons why when
people do big studies of of you know
what you know you can look at what what
people die of right what's on the death
certificate you know cancer heart
disease whatever heart attack
um and then you look at what caused the
cancer what caused heart disease when
people try to do that it's almost
impossible to separate diet and exercise
because people who tend to eat better
also tend to exercise more they're both
in our modern upside down topsy-turvy
world they're both markers of privilege
people have money to go to the gym
almost have money to buy healthy foods
and
um and people who care about their
physical activity also tend to care
about their diet so so at that level
they're very hard to separate however if
you're studying a particular component
of a system and it randomized controls
trial in a lab you can separate them out
and so we know that they have
independent and also interact of effects
what is the um the most important thing
we haven't talked about Daniel I think
the most important thing is that we need
to be compassionate towards each other I
mean there's so much shaming and blaming
and prescriptions and you know you know
the reason I entitled the book exercised
is that people we make people feel
exercised about exercise we make them
feel
uncomfortable and I'm confident and
shamed and and you know here you and I
are having this conversation but I can
tell that you you take you know you're
you're I mean I know I've listened to
enough of your podcast you care about
your your health and your care about
diet you care about exercise and people
may look at you and think gosh I wish I
was like him but uh it's just not me you
know I can't I'm not I'm not there right
and they may feel put off by our
conversation and I think that so often
these discussions make people feel feel
bad about about what they're doing and I
and I and I and I and I think that what
we need to emphasize is that if you put
you know if you put a chocolate cake and
an apple in front of me here I would
want to eat the chocolate cake and it
would I might eat the apple only because
you're there but if you weren't there I
would eat the chocolate cake right and
and when I'm in the in the in my
building at Harvard
my office is on the fifth floor of this
old Victorian building every single day
I want to take the elevator and the only
reason I take the stairs is that if
anybody catches me in the elevator I'll
be a hypocrite
it's not that I don't want to take the
elevator I do want to take the elevator
right I guess you guys say Lift right
um and and we make people feel bad for
taking the elevator right um they should
feel bad it's an instinct and so I think
we have to figure out ways to help
people
without shaming them and without blaming
them and without bragging and whatever
make you know you know talking about you
know the marathon they ran or this that
or the other
make them feel um less uncomfortable
about the topic and realize that you
don't have to spend the English Channel
or run a marathon or you know join your
WhatsApp group and do crazy hit workouts
every day by the way you don't need to
hit workouts every day get the benefit
um um instead just you know taking the
stairs in your building every day
anything is better than nothing and and
you'll get benefits from that and I hope
that that's the message that needs to
get out right anything is better than
nothing and if you can get started on
that on that on that pathway then it'll
it'll eventually become self-rewarding
and and that and that leads me to the
other topic that we didn't talk about
which is that the reward system of
physical activity you know you and I if
we go for like I'm really looking
forward to my run tomorrow morning in
the park I love running Central Park
it's one of the best places in the world
around right a fantastic view from the
top and it's just gorgeous right
um but when I run Central Park tomorrow
I'm going to get a big dopamine hit I'm
gonna my body's gonna produce all this
dopamine which is the molecule that says
do that again right it's a award
gamblers get dopamine hits right people
eat chocolate cake get a dopamine hit
right but if I were unfit and overweight
I wouldn't get that dopamine hit
and so when people start exercising they
don't get the reward that people who are
fit and and custom to doing it get and
then they're made to feel bad like you
didn't enjoy your run around Central
Park well it takes months if not years
before you actually get that reward
really yeah because because just like
being overweight causes you to become
insensitive to insulin you become
insensitive to all kinds of other
hormones in neurotransmitters and
dopamine is one of them so so it's not
an instant like benefit right it's hard
and so we need to be compassionate again
towards people who are struggling to
become fit and struggling to get the
reward and also if you're overweight and
you run around Central Park it's like
[__] if I were carrying weights and
running around Central Park it'd be much
harder right now it's you know it's
challenging and so we once you get you
know into that state it's hard to get
back to the state of activity and so we
we need as a as a society to to to help
those folks rather than judge them those
folks that are struggling and I was one
of those folks that were struggling for
many many years I was would say to
myself every year um pretty much all of
my adult life that this was going to be
the year that I'd get fit I try all of
these various different you know
fad exercise things by all this stuff I
announced in 2017 that I was going to
work out every single day and that
lasted for six months and then I yo-yo
back out of that it never stuck with me
until 2020 and that's I've been
exercising
six days a week since 2020 82 percent of
days and um
I reflect and try and diagnose how I
went from someone who what was it that
changed and if I can figure out what it
was that changed that the most
fundamental level in my mindset or my
attitude or my life or whatever it was
then I can help other people figure out
that too or at least give them more
sound advice or at least be more
empathetic whatever's required to help
them you know and I have a platform here
where I speak about exercise a lot on
these things so what's your suspicion
what's your suspicion on what it is that
makes people go from being you know
maybe having a um
a negative opinion towards exercise or
their ability to be disciplined with it
to
becoming an exerciser
do you know I've this is a question that
obsesses me in fact we have a big
project right now a big Grant to
actually study this oh really right now
um because I the more I study it the
more I think it's social
the more I think that
um
um again I think people are physically
active in our modern world exercise
for two reasons when it's necessary or
rewarding and what makes it rewarding
for most people is the social aspect and
that social aspect can take many
dimensions it can be running with a
group of friends and you know
you might want to go only
a mile but your friends convince you to
run another Mile right and you end up
running two miles right or you're
feeling bad and crappy and your you know
your friends help you do it or I'm a
running buddy right and I often you know
meet meet friends for early morning runs
and I can tell you that the evening
before it seems like a great idea to
meet Aaron at 6am on the corner of Mass
Ave and linnaean the next morning at 6am
I want to stay in bed with my wife you
know I don't want to I want to meet this
nasty smelly guy you know at 6am and the
cold dark but I agreed to meet him and
out I go right now I'm usually glad I
did it afterwards or um you know we can
go on there are other social ways in
which which but or dancing right I mean
nobody thinks of dancing as exercise but
it's exercise right
so that's one important social Dimension
and the other one though is
accountability
um I describe in the book I'm there's a
there's a friend of mine in San
Francisco who's struggling to just to
exercise
so she signed up for a program with this
company called stick.com I don't know if
you run across it where it's a
commitment contract where you send
like a thousand dollars to them and they
keep it in their bank account they
probably invest it make a lot of money
on it too but you set up a referee and
and you agree that I'm gonna not smoke
or this or that or the other or in this
case exercise and if you don't do it
and your referee is you know what you
know keeping track of what you do
you get to choose something negative so
in her case her husband is her referee
and if she doesn't walk I can't remember
what every day she has to walk a certain
number of miles her husband will will
tell her
and and or tell the website and it'll
send fifty dollars to the NRA that week
oh my God and she hates the NRA with a
burning passion what is the name right
and the National Rifle Association
they're they're the people who are
trying to prevent gun control
legislation in the United States and
they have effectively prevented gun
control like legislation United States
which is now kills more children than
cars in the United States so if she
doesn't exercise sorry she doesn't do it
then then money goes to this
organization that she hates so that's a
this is a stick if there ever was one as
opposed to a carrot and I don't think
she's every time I see her ask her you
know you kept up the walk he says oh no
the NRA hasn't gotten a penny right so
for her it's been very effective so it's
she's made a commitment contract that
that stings right that really hurts now
I think I might be a little on the
extreme side and I wouldn't necessarily
recommend that to everybody but but
she's accountable right she's made
herself accountable in some ways and I
think um people can find ways to make
themselves accountable to a friend
a loved one a parent you know priest who
knows what right
um You might or or hire trainer that's I
mean that's kind of what a trainer does
makes you accountable right and I think
so so those are again social ways to
help people be more physically active so
I think there are multiple ways of doing
that and I suspect that is going to be
the most effective sort of set of tools
that will help people one thing I
actually do is that on the screen saver
of my phone it has something that really
inspires me so I see it every day and
it's that reminder for me which
reinforces my my why across my life it's
actually my home screen on my iPhone is
actually a bit of a mood board for me we
have a closing tradition on this podcast
where the last guest leaves a question
for the next guest not knowing who
they're going to leave it for
and I don't get to see it until I open
the book um the question is what is one
aspect or feature of your life that
causes you the most friction
slash discomfort and how can you change
or fix it
I would say
um
it's my
tendency to compare myself to others
um
uh I you know
you know life is short life is precious
we're all experiments of one and uh when
I think about when I when I when I
engage in that oh so and so has such and
such
um that um that's a really bad habit
that's a really bad trade it never leads
anywhere good it only leads towards
either either I think about how I have
more of something than somebody else
that leads to
um uh I think unhealthy
uh feelings of Pride or feelings of
jealousy
um you know so-and-so has this award or
such and such and and uh that's um
that's kind of pernicious so I think
that's a bad habit that I uh I work hard
to to overcome
because it changes your expectations of
yourself and that chain takes steals
happiness it steals happiness yeah
it steals happiness thank you for the
work you do Daniel very important very
very important and increasingly
important I think um when we look at the
the health outcomes especially here in
the United States of people I mean you
actually share a number of them in the
book which I didn't didn't we didn't
really go into but they're just
horrifying yeah um it's scary out there
especially as it really relates to
exercise
um
there was one in particular that I wrote
down because it horrified me
I can't remember it was just all the
stats around the current Healthcare only
50 of Americans ever exercise ever
really ever ever
and only 20 meet those very minimal
World Health Organization standards
where where We're a nation of couch
potatoes and the rest of the world is
headed our way
but not if they get this book
because it I think it is a real
perspective changer and it's a real eye
opener and it's a necessary one so thank
you so much for writing it you're
fantastic at what you do and um I'm I'm
now a huge fan of your work after
delving in deeper and deeper and deeper
um so I can't wait to see what you do
next um well thank you and I recommend
everyone to go get this book exercised
because um
yeah I thought I knew a lot about
exercise but uh but from reading that
and having that window into a
hunter-gatherer ancestors and tribes and
other cultures it really that whole idea
of a mismatched life how mismatched my
life is in so many fundamental ways from
diet to exercise to socializing
um
and these kind of books help to
realign well thank you although it seems
that you're doing a pretty good job
trying you know I think we're so far
from being human though that yeah
there's still a long way to go for all
of us so thank you Daniel
[Music]
as you know Airbnb are a sponsor of this
podcast and I was actually in an Airbnb
last weekend when me and my friends had
a reunion in New York and it's from
staying in airbnbs over the years that
led me to start hosting my own place I
know friends of mine who actually Airbnb
their own place in order to pay for the
Airbnb they use when they're away on
holiday which is pretty smart and maybe
you stayed in an Airbnb before and
thought this is actually pretty doable
maybe my place could be an Airbnb it
could be as simple as starting with a
spare room or your entire place you
could be sitting on an Airbnb and not
even know it whether you could use some
extra money to cover your bills or
something a little bit more fun your
home might be worth more than you think
and you can find out how much it's worth
at airbnb.com
host check it out find out how much your
home is worth and let me know what you
think
[Music]
uh
foreign
[Music]